he was an American entrepreneur
cartoonist animator pioneer and
visionary he is widely regarded as a
cultural icon he's also a Hollywood
business mogul
he's Walt Disney and here his top ten
rules for success on this program a bit
of magic that's what the show is all
about you know when I arrived at the
studio in the morning my desk is always
nice and neat but it doesn't take long
for it to look like this however instead
of bothering my busy secretaries with
housecleaning problems I tidy up myself
it's really quite easy watch oh here we
go
I won two correspondents eat bacon eat
violet and so come on come on paper clip
talk sunday nice we would be my
grandmother's living room and they would
come walk dizzy on stream it was
something that you could share with
everyone and it always gave you joy the
first thing I did when I got a little
money to experiment I put all my artists
back in school we art schools that
existed then didn't quite have enough
for what we needed so we set up our own
art school or you were inventing in you
art anyway
well yes but we were just going a little
bit beyond what they were getting in the
art school where they work with the
static figure we were dealing in in
motion movement and the flow of movement
to flow of things you know action
reaction all of that so we had to set up
our own school and out of that school
would come the the artists that now make
up my staff here and more than that the
artists that make up all the most all of
the cartoon outfits in Hollywood uh-huh
we're directly or indirectly out of my
school I'm doing I think as much
animated cartoonists I've ever done the
only thing is I diversified I developed
a lot of talent over the years and I
couldn't use all of this time
for the cartoon so I went into the
nature films and then just for the fun
of it we went into doing films with
humans and oh it's just diversifying you
know makes the monotony things welcome
to a little bit of Florida here in
California this is where the early
planning is taking place for our so
called Disneyworld project now the
purpose of this film is to bring you up
to date about some of the plans for
Disney World but before I go into any of
the details I want to say just a word
about the sight of our Florida project
as you can see on this map we have a
perfect location in Florida almost in
the very center of the state in fact we
selected this site because it's so easy
for tourists and Florida residents to
get here by automobile now in larger
scale on this map our Florida land is
located partly in Orange County and
Osceola County between the cities of
Orlando and Kissimmee and the important
thing is that the Disneyworld is located
just a few miles from the crossing point
of interstate 4 and Sunshine State
Parkway florida's major highways
carrying motors east and west and north
and south to the center of the state the
sketches and plans you will see today
are simply a starting point our first
overall thinking about Disneyworld
everything in this room may change time
and time again as we move ahead but the
basic philosophy of what we're planning
for Disneyworld is going to remain very
much as it is right now
we know what our goals are we know what
we hope to accomplish and believe me
it's the most exciting and challenging
assignment we've ever tackled at Walt
Disney Productions the old saying these
are the things that dreams are made of
might well apply to the scale models and
the drawings and blueprints at least
when we dream up new ideas for
Disneyland they first take shape and
form in such luminaries studies as this
here at the studio we get many letters
from art students and from people who
are just interested in art some of these
letters ask questions that deserve a
more detailed answer than could be given
in a written reply and so from time to
time we're going to devote an entire
program to answering a few of these
questions in our future production of
Bambi the characters were developed by
drawing from life our our artists made
thousands of action sketches catching
every pose and characteristic attitude
in the production of Lady and the [ __ ]
this technique of humanized animal
characters reaches a point of near
perfection we first tried this approach
to humanized animal animation in one of
our early Silly Symphonies for this
project we brought some kittens into the
studio and let them play and roll about
as they pleased while the artist made
sketches and collected ideas for the
kitten story
result of this experiment was the
Academy Award winner of the year 1935
the three orphan kid
Epcot
will take its cue from the new ideas and
new technologies that are now emerging
from the creative centers of American
industry it will be a community of
tomorrow that will never be completed
but will always be introducing and
testing and demonstrating new materials
and new systems and Epcot will always be
a showcase to the world for the
ingenuity and imagination of American
free enterprise I don't believe there's
a challenge anywhere in the world that's
more important to people everywhere and
finding solutions to the problems of our
cities but where do we begin how do we
start answering this great challenge
while we're convinced we must start with
the public need and the need is not just
for curing the old ills of old cities we
think the need is for starting from
scratch on virgin land and building a
special kind of new community so that's
what Epcot is an experimental prototype
community that will always be in a state
of becoming it will never cease to be a
living blueprint of the future where
people actually live a life they can't
find anywhere else in the world where
they came about with my daughter's were
very young and I Saturday was always a
daddy's day with the two daughters so
we'd start out and try to go someplace
if you know different things and I would
take him to the Mary ground and I took
him different places and as I'd sit
there while they rode the Mary ground
did all these things sit on a bench
there eating peanuts
I felt it it should be something build
some kind of a my newsmen Enterprise
built where that the parents and the
children could have fun together
in Tomorrowland a monorail which started
operations only two years ago has
already outgrown its original circuit
its new extension leaves the
Tomorrowland area of the park two
parallel a modern freeway
along this stretch the monorails
passengers can experience the practical
application of transportation of the
future appropriately called a highway in
the sky the new Disneyland monorail
system covers two and a half miles not
only is the monorail system an
entertainment attraction but it's new
extension links the part with the
disneyland hotel it is not impractical
to believe that such a monorail system
could well be the answer to the growing
traffic congestion in our cities
well I guess you could call it
daydreaming that's the way Disneyland
was conceived a dream that grew into a
reality
I like em look let's don't forget that
darn cat the title the pictures
important thing we got to punch it yeah
mr. Jack Benny is here to see you Jack
Benny send them in wonder what he wants
well I thought he was still mad at you
for not using him in Snow White and the
Seven Dwarves finally got through to him
it was a cartoon Oh Jack hi wall
good to see you nice in you thank you
this is a real pleasant surprise
you know you don't come around here very
long now what a beautiful studio you
have here in this office
well I think after Mary Poppins I can
afford a redo
well no Esmeralda be quiet I've made it
wrong okay
everybody around here calls me Walt I
know Oh Jack what's on your money well
Walt is he tomorrow I'm doing an hour
television show with a large cast and
crew and I thought that instead of
taking him to dinner after the show the
Bistro or Chasen's that just for a
change I thought it'd be kind of nice if
I took them through Disneyland that is
if it's all right with you Oh Jack I
think it's a wonderful idea how many
people are there a hundred and ten
that's not too many is it no no in fact
we have a special department that
handles large groups at the discount a
discount yeah that means I know what it
means
look woof I was thinking you know with a
big show like mine I wind up with
practically nothing ten people I mean
even with them with a discount it was
really run into and since you see the
fact that you own the place
I thought maybe try and do it yourself
Jack pay no attention to him we're all
one big happy family whatever you can
say to me you can say in front of him
the wall as I was saying family now wall
as I was saying nice pussycat
walk as I would say you see a hundred
and ten Oh incidentally did you ever get
those four complimentary tickets I sent
you to one of my television shows
oh yes Jack thank you you know I almost
forgotten that was about nine years ago
what
yes mr. bother and I was saying I'm
taking a hundred and ten people to
Disneyland Oh Oh what I must tell you I
think it's just so wonderful the way
you're always taking groups of poor
underprivileged children through
Disneyland free of charge Jack we don't
publicize that how did you know my
sister's kid went once
yeah a wonderful time me she popped me
back some candy and everything
now wall it's silly to keep beating
around the bush what I was wondering
what wait a minute Jackson I think I'm
getting the idea you want a hundred and
ten free tickets well I had no idea
that's what you wanted
I'm only a bird so I see
wait a minute jack I seem to recall that
one Disneyland first opened I gave you a
14 carat solid gold past lifetime pass
to Disney yes you didn't give me a solid
gold pass well where is it here
okay hundred and ten three tickets and I
hope you all have a wonderful time
ah thanks thanks Walt hey listen you've
been so nice to me I'm going to do
something for you yeah what's that well
you know how important it is when a
motion picture is publicized on a
television show oh yes I certainly do
well I'll get on my show tomorrow night
I have a beautiful foreign actress and
we're going to do a foreign film you
know like they do in Italy in Italian
film and I'm going to rewrite the whole
thing so that it has a sort of a Walt
Disney approach but Jack I don't know
how you can possibly apply my
moviemaking approach to a foreign field
I mean everyone I see seems to be so
earthy so full of basic raw emotions
that's true that's true wall but don't
worry about it it'll work out huh but
there's such short time won't it be a
problem not when you're as creative as I
am
he's living in the wonderful world of
Benny
Oh worry about a thing it'll be great
and thanks so much for the tickets
I always glad to help a prime attorney
Jack goodbye Wow I was just thinking now
she's my wife Mary she's not on my show
but she's never been to Disneyland I'm
just thinking
my approach in an Italian movie this
we'll have to see what we're doing thank
you so much for watching I made this
video because Scott Pettigrew asked me
to so if there's a famous entrepreneur
that you want me to profile next leave
it in the comments below and I'll see
what I can do I'd also love to know
which of Walt Disney's top ten rules
meant the most to you leave it in the
comments I'm going to join the
discussion thank you so much for
watching
continue to believe and I'll see you
soon